resident Biden finally kicking off his
2024 campaign promising to unite the
country once again and get stuff done
just kidding old man Biden is back to
screaming about how evil Mega
Republicans are and they're going to
ruin the country
around the country Maggie extremists are
lining up to take on those Bedrock
freedoms cutting Social Security that
you paid for your entire life about
cutting taxes from the very wealthy
dictating what health care decisions
women can make Banning books and telling
people who they can love all while
making it more difficult for you to be
able to vote the question we're facing
is whether in the years ahead we have
more freedom or less freedom more rights
are fewer I know what I want
things you do too
where is he if you missed the big video
You're Not Alone Biden released it at 6
00 a.m when half the country was still
asleep and when Jesse had to get up to
change another diaper just like Dr Jill
let the thought of former four Motors of
Biden who says that he still has more
work to do
when I ran for president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are let's finish
this job I know we can because this is
the United States of America there's
nothing considering nothing we cannot do
for them
huh what job is he talking about Joe
didn't mention a single thing he has
accomplished or wants to do and his own
voters don't even want him 51 percent of
Dems say they just don't want to see
Biden run again and Republicans are
responding to the president's
announcement with a preview of what his
re-election would look like
all his 500 Regional banks have
shuttered their doors who's in charge
here it feels like the train is coming
off the tracks interesting Charlie
welcome to the show you look great
thanks for having me uh it wasn't my
choice so what's it like what's it like
when in four years since he's been
president he's saying that things are
still really really bad and we're on the
precipice of some kind of Armageddon but
he's been president for four years he's
almost arguing against himself being
elect re-elected yeah it's really
amazing I mean that video was as dark as
his initial four years ago or two years
ago his initial thing the only
difference is that that was about the
whole lie about Charlottesville and this
is about the mega semi-nazis or whatever
it is quasi-nazis it's just so dark and
depressing and you know you take a guy
like uh Barack Obama I didn't agree with
anything I didn't I didn't like him
didn't agree with his policies but you
go back to that 08 campaign and even a
little bit the 12 campaign it was so
optimistic and and you know gazing
towards the future there's none of that
with this guy it's so depressing it's
it's sort of a a sign of the times you
know uh Dana you noticed in that video
very you actually saw very little of Joe
and even when you heard him he was kind
of slurring it sounded like me on a
Friday night and you know Thursday night
it's one of those things when we do live
television you're gonna don't get an
opportunity to do it twice so sometimes
we slur or we stumble and that happens
when you're talking live yeah but in a
video like that it was highly produced
I'd give it you know passing grade it
was fine it's not going to win any
awards but it's answered the mail for
what they needed to do which is kick
things off so they can officially start
fundraising because they might think
that finishing the job will be easy for
them but I think that when only 25 of
the country thinks the job you're doing
is good you don't want it anymore like
who's going to answer the question are
you better off than you were four years
ago who's going to answer that and say
yes well perhaps very rich white
liberals who got the electric Vehicle
tax credit that might be something China
might answer that in the affirmative the
other thing I noticed is that it didn't
seem that there was the next campaign
like you were saying as well the looking
backwards not looking forward so what is
the new thing that he wants to do you
can't run the 2020 Playbook necessarily
because covet isn't around as you've
mentioned you can't necessarily be in
the basement so what's the new strategy
and maybe he won't need one I mean maybe
they maybe they think they can do this
because the media will be against
whoever the Republican is Trump DeSantis
Tim Scott any of them they're all of a
sudden they're going to be the ones that
will make America on the brink of losing
its democracy no matter who it is at
that time so judge it's basically like
he doesn't have to try like he did
before he stay in the basement you know
just yeah he picked just picked the Maga
Republicans 80 million voters or 70 what
a million voters forget China the
cartels our enemies just say it's them
yeah well the amazing part of it is
first of all he's had fewer press
conferences than any president in the
last I think it's 50 years and half a
century he doesn't want to have a
primary or RFK Jr wants to have a
primary uh and you know this guy talks
about the Constitution and making
America great well they're the ones who
shut down the 100 byten laptop worked
with his administration working with the
social media to make sure none of that
information came out which we now know
might have changed the election uh he
smug when the people in The Press Room
ask him you know can we ask some
questions he kind of laughs at them in a
very smug way and you know he was the
guy who came in who was going to unite
us he was the guy who was going to be
we're going to bring back America again
and we all want that and Obama had that
too Obama had that hope he had that you
can't take that away from him but this
President is dark and I'm always thrown
back those Marines and that dark blood
color behind him and he's promising now
to save assault from those men
Republicans and he does nothing but
divide Us in continuing divide us and
now do you realize that Kamala Harris
now is a Heartbeat Away not from a 78
year old but from an 82 year old and her
numbers are even worse than his so it's
like you know why don't you at least
show up now is this going to be a repeat
and finally let me just say that um
his whole Administration now is about a
certain kind of of it's I'm going to use
the word again a smugness like I don't
have to answer your questions and I'd
have to tell you about Hunter or
anything that I've done you know prove
it that's it you know Harold in the
green room I was really struck about how
how upset you were about this and you
said like I can't believe I'll probably
be voting for Trump I was shocked when
you said that it was right after I throw
your tie yes and then I said those
things that Charlie always good to see
you brother the um I'd say two quick
things first I agree with Dana and
Charlie and the way you he does there
was a Darkness says I thought this would
have been a more upbeat uh more positive
more we're grabbing for the future kind
of pieces as you saw with Clinton as you
saw as you've seen with your former boss
and others that will come
um there's no doubt bordering crime or
issues that I would imagine as well as
the Afghan pull out uh Afghan withdrawal
excuse me that will be talked about by
whomever runs against him whether it's
Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis or Tim
Scott or whomever Nikki Haley leave
anybody out but the election is 13
months away before we get really going
in this and if things continue like they
are and you begin to see some of the
fruits and some of the things they've
done so for example inflation is
trending down unemployment's at three
and a half percent prescription drugs he
lowered he capped insulin they've made
investments in it and ship production
here in America they've made investments
in onshoring more production and
Manufacturing in America they've made
investments in the infrastructure if
that stuff begins to pay off and you see
some return on investment there I could
see a commercial that begins to make a
case for the economic engine that the
president may have generated here or
maybe part maybe a reason for the
generation to it but interestingly
enough both of these leading candidates
Mr Trump and Mr Biden we said yesterday
six percent don't want Trump to run 70
percent on one bite in the Run they have
some commonality in terms of some of
their legal issues they both have a
special counsel looking into what they
did with certain documents President
Biden has his son's issues and president
Trump has a whole array of other legal
issues so we're in for a unique race and
I just think it's at this moment it's a
little early but I would agree I thought
that the that we made it a long time for
this and it was a lot of anticipation I
would have been a little more forward
leaning it would have been a little more
positive and the music would have been
more positive and I would have talked a
little bit more about the future than it
did but we're long ways away so we'll
see you know you want to tie back are
you soaking yeah I just kind of drifted
off but I um
what about what about the the elephant
in the room no Kamala there was no did
you guys she was in there she was in the
video more than I thought she would be
yeah really yeah wow did you also catch
the clip of him sprinting yes for three
seconds for three seconds no not even
three seconds yeah three steps yeah but
in a second but he was sprinting was he
on uh stairs falling forward
I went on Brian kill Mead I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now